Nós precisamos de um novo modelo. Esse
modelo cartesiano atual, ele tá muito
limitado. Então, a modelagem causal faz
uma pergunta diferente. Quais mecanismos
ligam intervenção à bioquímica e ao
resultado clínico? Ao invés de apagar as
diferenças, tirando a média, ela abraça
a individualidade usando biomarcadores,
raciocínio mecanístico, probabilidade
baesiana para inferir causa e efeito a
partir de múltiplos fluxos de evidência,
tá? Eu falei difícil agora, né? Falei,
parece até que eu tô inteligente agora.
Isso espelha como os clínicos realmente
pensam.
Então, quando a deficiência vitamina D
se correlaciona com disfunção imune ou
estresse oxidativo e desfechos ruins e a
suplementação restaura a função, isso é
inferência causal, não é coincidência.
Nice.